[Music]
this is balling no nothing classical
dances like waltzing tango this is an
underground scene that's been a safe
space of expression from gay and trans
people of color for decades it's kind of
like a mix between a dance floor and a
catwalk and this scene has created a
whole new form of music yeah I'm usually
like super afraid of cameras my cue is a
touring DJ drezz been producing ballroom
tracks for more than a decade and is the
founder of the record label Queen beat I
kind of feel like I'm talking to Diddy
Oh like created the first record label
in ballroom music so we're here in New
York to meet the dancers and musicians
of the ballroom scene and this week is
special because it marks the 50th
anniversary for the Stonewall Riots in
1969 uprising of gay and trans people
that took the fight for LGBTQ rights the
mainstream since before Stonewall the
barroom scene has provided a place where
the most marginalized people in American
society could feel a sense of community
and explore performances of gender and
sexuality black and latino gay and trans
people gathered to walk or compete at
balls
potestas strut down makeshift runways
wearing glamorous fashions voguing with
its angular model inspired dance moves
became a part of these runway walks in
the 80s participants vie for titles like
most real best
girl look best military look and
sometimes they're a part of a house or a
family like house of a ninja possibly
Beija or house of extravaganza for many
a house provides a surrogate family when
the real one has disowned them each
house has a mother and father who
provide mentorship for their children
should be part of a house not to be part
of extravaganza was family and looking
out for each other looking out for our
own
it's offending our own I am honored to
even be here today to call myself the
father of such a such a beautiful
organization josè extravaganza is the
father of the house of extravaganza he's
been a part of the ballroom scene since
the 1980s was 16 years old when I first
heard about the ballroom scene and
walked it down here as a matter of fact
and saw a whole like utopia of the world
but see as far as when the voting comes
to play I go back to where it's from
voguing is a feeling and it's an
attitude just self-expression as
individuals code is just one part of
walking but it might be the most
well-known name after the fashion
magazine bogan was introduced to the
mainstream in 1990 when Madonna released
her track folk it was the dance style
that inspired the song not the other way
around and when Madonna needed a vogue
expert she turned to Jose extravaganza
who choreographed and appeared in the
music video for the song it was a dance
that was created on on hold and dreams
for their community no it was a dance
that you know no technique was necessary
you didn't have to study it out of
school like other art forms of dance you
know at first bogan was all about
locking the body into perfectly straight
lines and awkward but visually stunning
positions kind of like the models in
Vogue magazine back then this was done
to disco or house music so as a
classical musician and it's just a music
appreciator in general I can after
hearing some volume tracks I can
recognize a similarity the kind of vibe
the culture behind it but I can't quite
put my finger on what exactly are the
musical ingredients that go into
creating a bond the track could you
break it down in your own words what is
the music started out which is house
music that was adapted into ballroom
before we got our own music the most
famous folk track of the 1980s was love
as a message by mfsb but in the 1990s
the ha danced by masters at work emerged
as a quintessential vogue track and it's
had the ultimate staying power that
track is self is just important like I
said that's just music that was regular
house music that was brought into
ballroom my cue has said that 90% of the
tracks he's produced have been Holly
Nyx's it's still considered the volu
song this came out in what 1991 the hot
dance includes a few things that make it
so iconic volg worthy and representative
of the genre minimal lyrics that allow
the commentator to presider lowballs
proceedings calling out categories and
pumping up the crowd
a civil crash on every fourth beat that
tells dancers when to dip to the floor
and of course the samples they were able
to catch that fourth beat that sound
which we call a hot crash so three four
one two three four that sample you hear
throughout the ha dance that iconic ha
come from Trading Places a 1983 movie
starring Eddie Murphy and Dan Aykroyd
the film doesn't hold up under modern
scrutiny at Cory's and blackface in the
scene but the song immortalized and
transformed that moment into something
for gay and trans people of color so a
lot of people think oh you know sample
the hop but just a hard crash in there
in this ballroom but that's not it still
that feeling that it has to embody and I
think you can only get that from
visiting a ball and being you know
immersed in the culture and seeing how
it is in feeling it like you invited us
to his monthly party house evokes so
that we could experience the ballroom
scene ourselves we wanted to learn how
ballroom music has evolved from the
early disco tracks and when we got there
they were pretty excited to have PBS in
the building
PBS is in the box
[Applause]
[Music]
legendary iconic GPS you the pinpoint
the hallmark sounds at walrus music what
would that be the hallmark sounds and
forward missing I would have to say
number one is the crash it's not like
[Music]
[Music]
today's ballroom tracks are a mixture of
disco funk hip hop house RB and
electronically TJ Vaughn the Lord he
came up and started making remixes like
actual remixes so he would take from all
those older house tracks and whatnot and
put into his remixes so that's kind of
where the formula started it the
repetitive bass beats and the cymbal
crashes tell dancers will just like the
poles or hit the floor
there's something special about the
collaboration with you and Mike you keep
talking about that
like on occasions I've been in for only
there's not too many DJ's that can
connect whoops a performer but you can
put anything hot out there you can go to
it but if the beat don't connect to what
you're doing you're not gonna get that
full storage I was gonna ask you if you
couldn't like show us where you get your
sounds from your favorite 808 the sub
there's that other only ask this so I
can steal your techniques so what I do
first is because I have a long process
the way that like I do stuff so I will
create loops at first in fruity loops
here okay
so yeah okay you plug-in okay yeah
samples and absolutely me just though
they're in increments it's like if
sixteen sixteenth notes one immediately
and at the top you're saying in groups
of four to be in it to be in it the
universal each instruments is triggered
at a different 1600 just start adding
you know I'll just add little elements
whatever I hear like in my head I'll
picture people bugging a lot just like
just the art of bugging or being edible
that's what I'm thinking about when I'm
making trance
[Applause]
one word that we kind of agreed on in
the car was ballroom music has an
unmatched attitude Mo's they had to
figure where I was just saying man I'm
like that relaxed but intense ballroom
tracks are meant to inspire competition
people meant to make me feel fierce when
you hear them like you're about to do a
battle on the dance floor
that's because voguing started as a way
to working out differences between
rivals in Paris is burning really ninja
known as The Godfather of voguing says
that when two or more people are voting
on the dance floor whoever had the best
moves
[Music]
[Music]
but I realize it's really like
sportsmanship it's like it comes with
the territory the tracks are also meant
to encourage and celebrate trans
femininity some of the most classic ball
tracks include founders that have
phrases and words in them that might be
offensive to the average listener but at
a ball it's high praise music is a
reminder of the enduring link between
the dance form and the performance of
femininity I want you to explain the
work
you look masculine his home okay but if
you go to if you go to vote and you so
soft and elegant whether it's like who
she's feeling you know it's like she is
this one is because you feel it your
femininity so usually why I say it's
usually just pertaining to the bow or oh
I'm feeling like and you said it has you
know kind of like the feeling you know
she's that means you're that meanwhile
Jordan know yo if don't even mean it
means yeah you can say Michael Jordan
but now we've got saying nah we'll say
like you're RuPaul and Dennis Rodman
ballroom may still be an underground
underappreciated subculture but we see
its influence everywhere from fashion to
movies to TV even the way we talk what
about some things that you can think of
that people commonly misunderstand or
yeah just misunderstand about ballroom
okay so the number one thing soon as you
get popped in my head is like everyone
they like to call the dip what we call
that drop with the death travel that's
the death drop or the shablam which I
don't know where they got that one but
yeah that's like more happy
so nice no shablam okay so it's called
the dip it's called the dip you're not
the death drop okay you heard it from
like you
while the scene becomes part of pop
culture these artists are making sure a
ballroom stays true to its origin a
celebration of gay and trans people of
color by creating music that is
distinctively their own I just don't
want to be exploited in such a way where
everyone is like so into it all that one
time and then next year and no one cares
about it is a trend or fad or something
yeah but it's not that because it's like
so many people put their like lies into
this and you know it's like everyday for
some people including myself
[Music]